in the film Gargamel gets this massive
jolt of power and the first thing he
does which I had mad respect for is he
gives himself better hair just if you
got a jolt of power could do anything
really really superficial what would you
do I would give myself a chin I'd make
my butt bigger yeah why not possible
I work clipping so I'm some hair to
myself I'd make it like like it's always
styled like I woke up and had perfect
hair and didn't have to touch it it was
just like I had a really weird crush on
jokey Smurf I don't know what it says
about me other than maybe I like Fineman
or have you ever had a really strange
crush oh you know I I did I had a crush
on the guy in the Barney suit because he
had to be like ribs to carry this 150
pound suit everywhere and so and he
happened to have like a really
good-looking face I had a crush on like
I listen there you go
I did not have a similar crash on Barney
I mean I don't know Simba was my guy
what is the weirdest thing you can do
with your voice
incredible biceps and the triceps and
he's always all day long just the
pumping weights is a really rich widow
voices like I'm a will baby thank you
sometimes when dick doing an ad do it
when I'm oh won't you swing I'm gonna go
through some of the Smurfs in this film
and tell me whether or not you possess
that trait the wall behind you oh you
know vanity I just made my chin I'm a
part of the generation that like takes
selfies table eating I just threw that
one in there there was a table eating
Smurfs I'm like what like the Snickers
commercial do you have a signature evil
laugh like Gargamel
[Applause]
my left is just evil and like
[Music]
you